[Music]
welcome back on to our next episode of
what's up prof
hello water.i nice to see you again
before we begin can you please open up
for us with a word of Prayer Heavenly
Father we are still talking about your
word and I pray that your Holy Spirit
will once again enlighten us and we
thank you for this promise in Jesus name
Amen amen
last time you were mentioning that the
King James was archaic in language would
you like to elaborate on that right well
that is what people said right I mean
today
I mean who uses words like the sign it's
it's so okay let us let us bring this
Bible up to modern times and changes
that's why the New King James was
basically produced in order to bring
about this change now let me make this
point and it's a very very interesting
and important point when the King James
translated were translating this Bible
that kind of language was no longer in
common use correct it wasn't used I mean
in the 1500s already they stopped using
the nominative accusative acquisition of
form of writing and whereas in the
earlier times you have had very specific
words to say who was being addressed the
the line being the various cases of the
singular address and then you had the
you yyy-you're which also the various
cases and plural forms now by the time
that the King James translators started
the common word that was used for
dressing people where the plural
angular was the word you yes whereas
previously you anything that started
with a y was plural and the King James
Version translators and the committee
made a decision to incorporate the older
form of the English which was no longer
in use and bring it into the Bible why
was that important now the reason why it
was important is because this book is a
legal document as we discussed last time
it's a covenant and we have to be very
precise as to who we are referring to
when we are dealing with a covenant is
God speaking to one individual is he
speaking to more than one individual is
he embracing the whole of humanity for
example these are very important issues
yes so now while today it might be
irritating to read about the the thy
thine ye your you etc it's actually very
important let me give you one example
Jesus is talking to Nicodemus and he's
telling him that you know do you not
know these things I mean you are a
teacher in in Israel and he says to him
I tell thee thee is with a T singular
he's addressing Nicodemus so thee is one
person and he's addressing him ye must
be born again that's plural yes so in
other words it affects all humanity and
now if you take a modern one it'll say I
tell you you must be born again he's
referring to
Nicodemus why are you not born again
he's talking team on a personal level
but no this is a doctrine that affects
the whole of humanity it's very
important to know who the parties are
that
are affected correct for example when
you go to the Old Testament where God is
speaking to Moses he says in the modern
translation how long will you not keep
my Commandments yeah he's talking to my
house is nice to be totally shattered no
no he's talking plural and you will only
pick it up in the King James Version so
the King James translators specifically
put that in here's my question do we
when we study the Word of God do we have
to be dumbed down to the level of the
mundane as we have it in the world today
or do we come up higher do we come up
higher so if you think again legal
documentation of High Court's standard
then they will also have that address
because I cannot say to you you must
because that's plural yes who are you
referring to of the pleura plurality I
have to be very specific and the various
cases are also there now in German those
cases are still used to this very day
now if you take the Afrikaans
translation for example those cases are
gone interestingly if you take a NIV if
you take that verse on Nicodemus for
example then he'll be only talking to
Nicodemus and not speaking generally
that everybody has to be born again but
the Afrikaans actually has it right so
the if it's the old translation in the
German has it right and even in the
modern ones you'll still get it because
that kind of language is still being
used so to me it's very important and
it's become it's become like a hobby
that when you read and you find the V
and the VY it's fascinating to me who is
he actually talking to yes and it makes
the Bible come
so it's not a negative it's a plus yeah
also when it comes to the translation of
those that are based of those
translations that are based on those
other two flagship manuscripts that come
out of the Alexandrian stable then there
are literally hundreds of verses that
have been changed yeah and I don't think
it's the forum of of this talk to go
through all the verses that have been
changed it would take us forever
but it is interesting to me that the
main character who is Jesus Christ
should always be denigrated made less
than what he is in the new translations
yes rather than in the old one even if
you take the the New King James it will
say that the servant Jesus the servant
rather than Jesus the son the son of God
and whenever there are particular verses
that are being mentioned that differ
from the King James and and the New King
James was apparently written in order to
bring this one up to modern language if
that was the only reason just to bring
to modern language because in the end to
take out the archaic language and in the
end it had thousands of changes correct
now you know what's interesting is that
if you read words in in the King James
Bible that's why I like the King James
Bible that doesn't make me a King James
Bible only one but if you read words
that you do not understand because the
literary style is still retained and you
have this Hebrew parallelism yes it'll
give you the verse in one way using one
kind of language and give you the same
meaning parallelism in another fashion
so that the Bible actually explains
itself it becomes its own dictionary the
King James absolutely you've hit the
nail on the head this is its own
dictionary where's the other one you
don't have that no and the language is
often far more complex
and where the King James will say
something in in a very pertinent fashion
using very direct language the other one
will describe it in such a fashion that
you do not know who's who in the zoo
in the end so it's not an improvement
but let's not talk about that whether
it's an improvement or not why are there
so many verses changed why are there so
many pertinent differences why when
there is a difference do they follow the
eggs Alexandrian version if they're
supposedly are translating from the
received text while they're going the
using the other manuscripts that makes
no sense
yes but let me talk again about covenant
because if this is a covenant between
God and man and the Bible says that I'm
the Lord I change not I do not change
what is gone out of my mouth you may not
add to it you may not subtract from it
and if you do so then the plagues will
be added to you doesn't it say that in
the Bible revelation in other words do
not change God's Word now all modern
Bibles are copyrighted yes they're
copyrighted and you will see that
they're copyrighted the King James
Version is not copyrighted so it's
available to everyone it doesn't belong
to any particular entity it is God's
Word that has been translated yes now if
you copyright something and you say that
you own it then it cannot be the sign of
something that has gone before
it must be substantively different by
definition now excuse me when you make
something substantially different from
the Word of God in order to comply with
copyright law do you still then have the
Word of God or do you
the word of man posing as the word of
God
yes well legally it has to be different
now not just different in terms of a
word here and there but even different
in thought so if you go to the book of
Hebrews and this one says that he went
into the holy place the King James and
the New King James says that he went
into the most holy place well which of
the two is it now yes which one is the
Word of God or do we guess do we toss up
a coin how do I know what we are talking
about if you take the NIV which is of
course in my opinion a totally reduced
text because it has so many pieces
missing from the original which is
supposedly expanded but we've spoken
about that then do you still have the
Word of God or do you have something
else and whatever it is the exact
opposite is of what this word says do we
didn't have a choice I mean I'm always
surprised when people say it doesn't
matter what Bible you use you will find
Jesus that's possible because I have no
doubt that even the NIV contains the
Word of God don't i refresh that
carefully I have no doubt that the NIV
or any Bible even the worst of them
contains the Word of God but I don't
want to be crumb hunting I want to know
what is the Word of God and that is why
in my own experience I had to progress
from one to the other and eventually I
am reading a document that tells me who
the parties are that are being addressed
it gives me the precise wording for
example if you take documents or
doctrines on the sanctuary it's very
important to know where is Christ
ministering yeah if you take the book of
Revelation
and in the first portion he is walking
amongst the candlesticks then you know
that he's and the holy places not in the
most holy place so why did he go into
the most holy according to the modern
translations when the King James says
otherwise
and even in the prophecy itself in the
book of Revelation it says otherwise so
it's very important to me how accurate
this Bible is and where we are going so
a covenant is a precise document it must
be based on the exact wording of the
parties concerned and if you've changed
it then it can no longer be that
covenant so it is a it is a book it is a
book about God maybe but it's not the
government document it's not precise
just to go back their legs and dream
text what year about did that come to be
you said there was about 45 or so copies
of that what is the history if we can
just trace it because that's now past
the disciples and the Apostles yes so
from the the the the period up until the
xlx and Riaan what happened they well
there were these two streams of
documents right the byzantine documents
on which the received text which is
called the received text and then you
have the Alexandrian documents and the
early church no doubt used the Byzantine
text correct and you can go back to the
earliest translations Armenia for
example that was one of the first
translation it's received text if you go
to the the Orthodox Church in the East
it is received text and what Rome used
and what the Western world used was
basically the other text right and we
spoke about the Vaticanus yes now
whether
that document come from by the way that
one also has been scratched out and
changed so it no longer qualifies as a
covenant document with all those changes
but nevertheless there are those who
thought it was an ocean of purity so
where does it come from and what is its
origin now
when Christianity became the accepted
religion in the Roman Empire yes
Constantine was the one who made
Christianity acceptable yes and he
probably ordered a translation and a
bishop by the name of Eusebius who was a
follower of Oregon who by the way was a
gnostic yes and believed that Jesus was
a created being he probably made a a
Bible manuscript or made one translated
once that was used and the Vaticanus is
probably a copy of that as would be the
Sinaiticus now the Sinaiticus was found
in 1844 that's a fascinating date to me
by the way and just in time for the new
translations and the Bible societies and
what's also interesting as we discussed
earlier the King James Committee was
totally Protestant yes all of these
modern Bibles have on their committees
Jesuits yes Unitarians and Unitarians
and people who do not believe in the
preservation of the Bible that's why
they have eclectic text where they take
this and this and and they call these
modern translations dynamic equivalent
you know it sounds so intellectual this
is a dynamic equivalent now if you break
those words up what does it mean dynamic
means ever-changing so it's ever changed
the ever-changing Word of God I am the
Lord I change not
we have a Coptic dissonance it's a
oxymoron and then you have equivalent
now what is an equivalent it's something
like similar yeah similar but it's not
the same thing so you have a dynamic
ever-changing something that equates to
is similar to this that's ludicrous yeah
they were already disqualifying
themselves as the Word of God just by
the terminology that they are using so
what do we do with all of these
translations so do they they come via
this line this Eusebius line now your
CBS was a bishop who favored and loved
the kings of the world and curried favor
with the world yes and being a scholar
who was a student who studied Oregon
then it was probably Gnostic right and
jerome used those manuscripts to produce
the Vulgate yes and the Vulgate it's
interesting that they used the word
vulgate which means the common language
right now actually that is there is a
theft yes that's what the earliest latin
translation of the received text was
called it was also called the Vulgate so
the not to be confused with the Vulgate
that is used by roman catholicism that
is probably based on these manuscripts
that were produced by Eusebius now this
vulgate became the standard Bible of the
Roman Catholic Church and at the Council
of Trent of the Reformation the Vulgate
was again elevated to that ocean of
purity this infallible Word of God that
even the Pope's had changed over and
over to bring it in line and in in the
writings of Ellen White for example it
states quite clearly that this
manuscript was full of errors
and that these manuscripts that became
available for the translation of
Luther's Bible and Tyndall's Bible and
eventually also the King James these
manuscripts were xanthine now how did
they come to the West and why were they
gone they were there but they were in
the East right yes and then there was
this this battle that took place between
the West Europe and the Turks and the
Turks invaded Constantinople and all of
those regions and the scribes of the
East fled to Western Europe taking their
manuscripts with them and so these
manuscripts became available and were
compiled and these manuscripts
eventually ended up in the hands of
Martin Luther now it's true that
Catholic scholars were involved what
Luther being one of them I mean after
all he was a Catholic priest wasn't a
great but it's not a question of who
handled them it's a question of where
did they come from guess so Erasmus for
example who compiled these manuscripts
on which we today base the received
takes he was a Roman Catholic scholar he
was let's put it this way
almost a Protestant yeah almost a
Protestant and Martin Luther and Tyndall
and then used these manuscripts to base
their their translations on and Roman
Catholicism was actually in a dilemma
because Erasmus was one of theirs but
they were adamant at the Council of
Trent later that the Vulgate was the one
that it was to be based on yes and we've
discussed that before the Vulgate was so
full of errors and it had of course also
in it where you can worship the top of
your stuff and drive our demons with the
gallbladder of a fish I mean such a
ridiculous nonsense
in there and that is why the manuscript
line that was used by God when it was
possible to produce the Bible in mass
because of the invention of the printing
press it was based on the received text
and it is the Protestants that gave the
original text back to humanity
it is not Catholicism that harbored the
Bible and made it available you know
what giving numbers to texts that's
nothing that's not the Word of God
yeah the Word of God is what is
contained in the writing and that is why
I believe the received text is the
unadulterated Word of God with thousands
of manuscripts substantiating in harmony
with each other that it is indeed the
Word of God you will have certain verses
where they say oh these were added or
and this was added like the Jelani and
comma and you know where it clearly
talks about the Father the Son and the
Holy Spirit now there have been uncles
that have been found that substantiate
that that was originally in the text
ancient ones older than the Sinaiticus
or any one of those that's one thing
that you also also always hear is that
but these latest ones are older than the
documents of the received ticks yes
because the original ones the autographs
those that were actually written by the
disciples and by Paul etc they have been
not lost but they have disintegrated
because of use yes so we have copies of
it based on the promise of preservation
right so yes the others were preserved
longer because of disuse
yes yes so which ones do we actually
trust and my view is the received text
is the unadulterated Word of God and it
is not an expanded text can you give us
a few examples oh you know there are so
numerous that one wouldn't know where to
begin and there are so many excellent
books that have been written on this
issue our authorized Bible vindicated by
Wilkinson he's an excellent book and it
was probably one of the the pioneers
saying that we should go back oh he also
received a lot of flack of course yes
and he wrote an answer to those and we
can talk about that as well an excellent
little book that has come out quite
recently is thou has magnified thy word
above all thy name by Martin Klein and
you know there are so many authors that
have written about this issue and some
of them are really wonderful scholars
and so something I will I will put it in
there in the I wrote the document but I
never published it as a book it's called
Bible versions does it matter which
Bible we use and I never published it
because you know I received so much
headwind as a consequence of these
things we will make that available also
available and here are a couple of
statements that I found very interesting
now what does Satan propose to do he
proposes that he is capable of changing
this Bible these parties that fell
understand all about heaven and that
they can bring in the different
sentiments from the Bible and they are
going to have a revision of it you will
see they will make revisions of the
Bible but every one of us
needs to stand intelligent Leon the word
we cannot afford to be careless we must
have that simplicity of godliness that
is a virtue to us we must have it
it is the mind and character of the
persons who study the scriptures that
make the study dangerous the
difficulties will be removed from the
way of those who search the Scriptures
with earnest humble hearts praying to
the Lord for wisdom there is to be no
cutting out of Scripture no mutilating
the word as Catholics have done the
Bible is to be searched as a whole the
things in it hard to be understood will
become plain through the enlightenment
of the Holy Spirit do you desire to
destroy the covenant between yourselves
and your God a perpetual government
means just what it says it is a sign
between me and the children of Israel
forever God declares for in six days the
Lord made the heaven and earth and on
the seventh day he rested and was
refreshed this is our evidence you will
see ear long that there will be those
who will become weary of hearing
repeated the things that they ought to
do but do not desire to do and they will
change the wording of the Bible we know
what the Lord says in revelation about
those who do that a perpetual covenant
is a perpetual covenant if we want to go
and have a look at a couple of specific
verses and you know let's just take the
New King James for example because this
is supposed to be just a correction or
bringing the James up to to the modern
language format revelation 19 verse 8
and to her was granted that she should
be arrayed in fine linen speaking about
the Church of God clean and white for
the fine linen is the righteousness of
of saints now you know the Bible is
quite clear that we have no own
righteousness and that there's no one
righteous no not one all our
righteousness is filthy rags so the only
righteousness that we can lay claim to
is the imputed and imparted
righteousness of Jesus Christ now the
King James says it quite beautifully and
that the church is arrayed in fine linen
and that this fine linen is the
righteousness of the saints
but by implication we know comparing it
to the other verses that this isn't
imparted and imputed righteousness the
New King James says and to her it was
granted to be arrayed in fine linen
clean and bright for the fine linen is
the righteous acts of the saints
that's Catholic doctrine yes that is not
Protestant doctrine and it's not
received text the NIV is even worse it
says fine linen bright and clean was
given her to wear fine linen stands for
the righteous acts of God's holy people
the one who is holy is God and if he
wants to call us holy let him do that
but let us never utter it now another
interesting one for example is Genesis
chapter 22 verse 8 where it says and
Abraham said my son God will provide
himself a lamb for a burnt offering
so they went both of them together now
this is such an important verse because
it's a type yes of the sacrifice that
God would bring in the form of his son
right director now the King James is so
beautifully clear and Abraham said my
son God will provide himself miss Allen
who was the Lamb that he provided
himself Jesus was Jesus now why did he
provide him now let's read the New King
James
and Abraham said my son God will provide
for himself the lamb excuse me
God doesn't need a sacrifice for himself
he has never sinned I am the one who's
the sinner you are the one who is the
sinner and God will provide a lamb to
atone for your and for my seventies I
mean the whole theology is ridiculous in
the New King James Version Matthew
chapter 20 verse 20 then came to him the
mother of Zebedee children then came to
him the mother of Zebedee's children
with her sons worshiping him and
desiring a certain thing of him King
James Version and if you look at the New
King James then the mother of Zebedee's
sons came to him with her sons kneeling
down and asking something from him it's
not the same thing it shows the deity of
Christ in the first one I mean the list
is endless Matthew chapter 20 verse 26
but it shall not be so among stew but
whoever will be great amongst you let
him be your Minister the New King James
says let him be your servant
yea there's a difference between
ministering and being a servant you can
serve while being a minister yes but
there is a definite difference I mean
the list is just endless Hebrews chapter
9 of course is very important to the
Ministry of Jesus we have a high priest
who is a type who is an anti-type of the
type that was here in the Old Testament
verse 12 says neither by the blood of
goats and calves but by his own blood he
entered in once into the holy place
having obtained eternal redemption for
us the New King James has him entering
into the most holy place
now they will say you know the verse
actually says sanctuary it doesn't
actually specifically say but the one is
totally incorrect and the other one is
correct
or which one is correct is it a guessing
game no they have a guessing game on
these issues God's Word and not because
it's important issues let's take Romans
chapter 3 verse 22 even the
righteousness of God which is by faith
of Jesus Christ over and over again
it talks about the faith of Jesus Christ
in the King James Version and if you go
to the original it doesn't actually say
that but the grammar tells you that it
is Jesus's faith for example the grandma
tells you that the King James is
accurately translated and the new
translations will all say in not off the
faith in yes now is there a difference
between whether it is the faith of Jesus
or whether it is the faith in Jesus
obviously I must have faith in Jesus
that's not incorrect I must have faith
in Jesus but to have the faith of Jesus
comprises so much more so when he leads
the faith in Jesus absolutely
what did Jesus believe did Jesus believe
in the flood yes obviously because he
says as it was in the days of Noah and
the flood came and took them all the way
did he believe in creation yes did he
believe that God created them in the
beginning male and female yes he
believed all of those things did he
believe that Jonah was in the belly of a
fish yes he actually believed now so
that's the faith of Jesus today you can
negate all of those things in the Bible
and still claim to have faith in Jesus
so these are differences that are very
very
important if you go to Revelation
chapter 14 here's the patience of the
saints here are they that keep the
commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus so again you have this important
issue that you have to believe the whole
word a criteria for being part of God's
final that's the faith of Jesus you see
off Jesus didn't he answer the devil by
saying man does not live by bread alone
but by every word that proceeds out of
the mouth of God it is written he said
to the devil it is written so we have we
have some really very big problems so I
don't want to go into all the many
verses that are changed you can take any
issue take clean and unclean I mean the
NIV goes so far as to say here by Jesus
declared all clean foods clean which is
not at all in the original text so you
base an entire false theology on it on a
Bible text so we have to be very very
careful are we dealing with the Word of
God or are we dealing with an eclectic
text by their own admission the modern
translations are eclectic therefore they
cannot be the Word of God because they
take other sources so they may have a
believed that the autographs were
inspired by God but they're not
available so now what is the Word of God
let's pick and choose and pick it up in
the deserts and and see if we can find
one somewhere in a hole no God doesn't
work like that
and God would never negate and set aside
entire generations in order to give
these manuscripts to humanity here at
the end of time that they suddenly have
the Word of God which happens to be in
perfect harmony with manuscripts that
are corrupt like the Vulgate for example
and had to be changed by the very people
that proposed that they were Unger
you know even in Adventism there's
different Bibles how do you feel about
these well you know what originally
everybody had the King James and the
Pioneers used the King James Bible this
world of prophecy used the King James
Bible yes she used some of the modern
ones when they came in but later on she
used them less and less and less and in
the last one she didn't use them at all
correct and do we have some translations
that are not King James Version for
example well let's say the clear word
for example is that now an Adventist
Bible no it is the work of one
individual who made his study notes and
basically it's being used as a Bible and
I don't use it at all yes I don't have a
beef if somebody wants to read what his
thoughts were just as I have no beef if
somebody wants to read a Bible
Commentary to see what the theologians
think about a certain text but when I
want to know what did God say I have to
go to a literal translation of what God
said and that will take me back to the
King James because it is a literal
translation that has all the criteria
necessary to be a covenant document
between God and man I will use an a
received text translated Bible that has
not been influenced by eclecticism and
that has not been influenced by the
other manuscripts that were found in
waste paper baskets where they belong
thank you very much Walter a very
important discussion because we have to
know what the truth is and what's God's
Word
thank you for watching we'll see you in
the next episode again
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe click yes when the bell
appears click and you will receive
notifications to watch the next one
click yeah thank you again and see you
next time